we have once again multiple examples of these
strange brain glitches that some are calling
colloquially mini-strokes happening to Donald
Trump from last night.
State of the union speech, I don't know what
this is.
I am not a medical professional.
I have gotten emails from neurologists who
say, David, these seem possibly like mini-strokes.
Sometimes dementia can cause this.
Sometimes it can be medication, it can be
drug abuse.
Some say it's Parkinsonian.
I don't know what it is, but something is
not right.
I'm going to play for you two examples from
last night.
It's very visual.
So if you're listening to the podcast or on
the radio, find the video on our YouTube channel.
What happens is that Donald Trump will simultaneously
mess up a word, sort of like the record skips,
and sometimes he'll say a nonsense word, and
at the exact same time his shoulders spasm
and he seems to sort of turn to cover it.
He looks confused for a moment and then he
goes back to reading the teleprompter.
In this first clip, Donald Trump is trying
to read the word sanctuary from his teleprompter.
We noticed this one live on the state of the
union stream last night, and instead Donald
Trump says sanctuary.
And right when he says it, his body spasms,
the shoulder Twitch happens in Trump turns.
Let's take a look at this first clip.
California passed an outrageous load declaring
their whole state to be a sanctuary for criminal
illegal, the state of California, an outrageous
law declaring their whole state to be a sanctuary
for criminal illegal.
The state of California passed an outrageous
law declared.
Again, it's like the record skips Trump, mrs
or miss States all or part of a word, his
shoulders spasm and then he goes right back
to reading after a brief moment of confusion.
Here's another example from last night.
This one, Trump is talking, he's either talking
about caseum Solemani or Abu Bakr al-Baghdadi
and Trump was trying to say he directed the
December and he glitches.
He says, [inaudible].
He says that he directed the December and
simultaneously the shoulders flinch, Trump
spasms, and then Trump turns to sort of try
to cover it almost like he knows that it's
happening.
Bonnie orchestrated the deaths of countless
men, women and children.
He directed the December to salt and went
on to assault us forces in Iraq.
We're not making fun of medical conditions.
We're noticing that this is happening.
There's not an explanation that has been given.
There's no serious medical evaluation that's
been done of Donald Trump that we can trust.
The one we have says he's six three and weighs
239 pounds.
If you believe that I've got a bridge to sell
you and this does not seem normal.
Now a couple of other reminders of recent
examples.
This, uh, this was one on, uh, the word criminals
at a recent rally where the same type of glitch
happened.
Democrats decided to shield and shelter crim.
Look, look, wait.
You have criminals, a Washington president
here in Wildwood, New Jersey.
I just wanna get a quick comment before we
toss it over to Tucker, Molly Hemingway,
and then remember another recent instance
of this while Donald Trump was speaking to
the right wing group, turning point USA.
And let me begin by wishing you a beautiful
egg.
Look here.
Remember this.
You remember they were trying to take Christmas.
We want to know what's going on.
Quite simply, it is happening too much for
it to be nothing.
The confusion on Trump's face, the spasm and
the recognition that something seems to have
happened that Trump seems to experience suggests
to me this is not nothing what it is.
I don't know.
I hope at some point we learn and we figure
it out.
Let me
know
what you think.